I think our daughters are friends I
think that makes us friends I'm hunter
I'm Lisa my Julie Mitchell Hills hero I
[Music]
can't believe it's romper so grown-up
can you hug my daughter anymore without
feeling her boobs just our kids oh we
don't understand what they're saying so
it's not snooping teenage emoji
eggplants are dicks
oh jeez have a secret like trees are we
and this thing is yummy she's gonna get
rose kit and then touch his dick
eggplant gonna drool come out of this -
that's jizz stand down it is they're
planning on losing their virginity on
prom night
[Music]
through I'm gonna stop them I'm in let's
[ __ ] block those [ __ ]
this is our last big night together this
past economics not even more important
away WWV didi what would Vin Diesel do
[Music]
in terms of prices parents who notice if
we humans joke what the [ __ ]
so messed up your dad try to stop you
when you wanted to lose your virginity
was too busy high-fiving
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about a little chugging contests
bringing her but what we're but
chuckling you got this dog no I'm
tagging out you're in what you put a
baby everything's looser down there a
baby out of my back on the count of
three I'm tripping so hard I just had a
vision
my dad was chugging beer it was [ __ ]
[Music]